kyle hendricks
three and two this year era in the low
threes he's got excellent control he
moves the ball
doesn't use the middle of the plate and
he is tough to deal with tim
anderson first up for the sox tim on the
ground left-hand side body off at
dive and tim's safe he beat it out that
was a great play by bodhi but
tim anderson doing what he does best
getting aboard early and he hit this
ball hard
now seven game hitting streak for
anderson here's john montana who had
yesterday off
anderson not running call strike three
got him on an outside fastball here's
yasmani grandall
change up swung on and missed strike
three and that's out number two
back-to-back strikeouts for kyle
hendricks jose abreu now strides to the
plate with a runner at first no score
two outs i think right now this is the
true test for
kyle hendricks because abreu is the one
seeing the ball the best in the lineup
and it's a jam shot roller right up the
middle into center field at base head
anderson turns second on his way to
third
so jose abreu goes the other way from
the shift and is now first and third
with two outs here in the top of the
first inning and another
hit for abreu he's now hit in seven
straight as well the batter eloy jimenez
hits a pop fly this might be playable
foul territory it is for contreras he's
got it and hendricks puts a zero on the
board
so ronaldo lopez making his first start
since the third game of the season
not exactly sure how long a leash that
lopez will have here
tonight as being his first start back
ian happ leads off for the cubs
now the three one to half very high ball
for ian happ
doing his job as the leadoff man getting
on base let's see if that leads to
bigger and better things
here is anthony rizzo and that's hit in
the air into deep right field turning
around now as mazzara he'll make the
catch there at the warning track
one away and it brings up bios and the
next offering from lopez is strike three
called right down the middle at 96 miles
an hour
there's kyle schwarber to the plate now
the runner at first base and two outs
and that is strike three called 97 miles
an hour right at the knees
so ronaldo lopez after the lead off walk
gets the next three
and edwin has a leadoff double and the
sox third hit
in six batters and luis robert who leads
the league in first pitch swings
at nearly 57 of the time
and he does right here and lobs a
grenade to center field and gone
first pitch assault and a two-run shot
that is just the way they started last
night it's quickly
two-nothing white sox here in the second
inning ronaldo came out this inning and
he wasn't the same pitcher he was in the
first maybe it was the length of time
between innings now he's got two on
nobody out
now he really has to battle his weight
to get out of this and carratini has
been swinging the bet
very well garatini drives one in the air
toward left back goes jimenez jimenez
still going back
it's over his head off the wall and
bouncing away two runs are going to
score on the double and the ball game is
tied two to two the cubs
have two runs in the first and seven
batteries tonight against lopez two outs
back to the top for eagan half in this
2-2 game here in the second inning
that's a high fly ball
into shallow center right there is luis
robert one hand grab hitting over
but damage done is lopez gives up the
two-run double but does
strand the go-ahead run deloitte at
first base now with two house for edwin
and carnacion
will throw to first again that throw off
to mark but oh look out last
everybody all right what a crazy looking
play man oh man
i don't know how and kardashian
did not run completely over you know
what laza's trip
actually saved i've never seen that
before last santa sniper got me
laz is never going to hear the end of
this 2-2 as we head to the top of the
sixth inning and jose abreu will lead it
off
jose to right field well struck very
well struck and out of here
bring him home for the lead top six
and kyle hendricks disgusted with that
2-0 pitch
right over the heart of the plate to the
hottest hitter back-to-back
sharp singles here in the white sox
seventh inning they already lead by a
run
and the batter now is tim anderson
anderson hits the ground ball to short
baez goes to second there's one keptness
to first
that's a double play just what the cubs
needed
six four three on the twin killing so
runner at third with two outs
and it brings up moncada oncotta hits a
high pop fly
playable baez behind second is calling
in very shallow center he'll make the
catch and that ends the end
good job by ryan tapara gio gonzalez
who's been in
since the fourth inning he got the final
two out to the fourth and then got
double plays in the fifth and sixth
to close out the cubs you would think
he's out there on a very short
leash at this point two gone it will
bring up jason kipnis
down low he walked him and gonzalez is
mad at himself
this means he has to face david bodie
now
with a guy on base renteria has not
yet made the call is renteria going to
stay with gonzalez here
i believe he will that's a high fly ball
into left field eloy jimenez measuring
this one up right at the warning track
he'll make the catch
inning is over good start here to the
eighth inning the lead-off walk
and that will bring up the red-hot jose
abreu rowan wick
he has gone 45 in the third innings
without allowing a home run that dates
back to september 9th
of 2018. oh it hung jose
in the air left field way back
bring him home again a cement mixer to
beat
all cement mixers and it's five to two
the homer streak is history for wick
cubs now have two men on okay
the stage is set the tying run is at the
plate
wilson contreras coming up bouncer
toward the middle it's going to be a
base hit
round and third heading home baez the
cubs get a step closer
and now it's a five to three ball game
so here's jason hayward and the pitch
hit in the air to straight away center
field luis roberts got plenty of room
there he'll make the catch and the
inning has come to an
end two down grand all coming up
yasmani in the air center field half is
back he's at the track at the wall
gone a little extra from he has tonight
and six three the sox lead
would be nice for a three-homer game for
abraham sure
he'd like it that's a high fly ball deep
left field
it's a trifecta jose abreu has gone deep
for the third time tonight
seven to three white sox lead in the
night and jose abreu as hot as we have
ever seen him and it is alex colimay in
this ball game
hubs have managed second and third half
will come up bouncing ball to the right
side fielded by mendic he'll throw to
first
in time a run scores but now there are
two down
and anthony rizzo will try to keep the
cops alive
center field roberts got it in the sox
win a
seventh in a row and a chance for a
sweep tomorrow